[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour today it's my immense
pleasure to be able to welcome dr
michael eric dyson to the addie hour for
a conversation about race community and
mental health this is someone who
obviously needs no introduction but i'm
going to go ahead and give a brief one
anyway
dr dyson is the centennial chair at
vanderbilt university and also a
university distinguished professor of
african american and diaspora studies in
the colleges of arts and sciences and a
university distinguished professor of
ethics and society in the divinity
school he's someone who also is a new
york times contributing opinion writer
also contributing editor at new republic
and espn's the undefeated has written
numerous books has another book coming
out very soon which we'll probably talk
about on this podcast as well and he's
someone who has won lots of prestigious
awards including an american book award
two naacp image awards and ebony has
also cited him as one of the 100 most
influential african americans and one of
the 150 most powerful blacks in the
nation
so someone who continues to contribute
to public discourse and public debate on
places like the late show with stephen
colbert real time with bill muller good
morning america the today's show all
things considered to have a smiley deaf
poetry jam the list goes on and on but
all that to say is that i'm very
grateful that he's taken time out of his
busy schedule dr dyson i really
appreciate you being here on the idaho
podcast and welcome
thank you sir it's always uh great to be
with a distinguished uh intellectual and
uh you know influencer like yourself so
uh thanks for having me on of course and
i appreciate those kind words and really
excited about this conversation um so
again you know just with the the uh all
the impact that you have in your place
is such a distinguished scholar and
cultural critic
baptist preacher activist influencer a
lot of the topics that you touch on are
really near and dear to the
conversations that we have on this
podcast as well especially as we think
about how aspects of race racism social
justice and equity impact and interact
with mental health in this country um so
i just wanted to start out you know my
listeners know i like to just check in
and see how people are doing so in the
midst of everything that's going on with
the ongoing pandemic with kova with the
ongoing systemic racial injustices even
as we are preparing for the start of the
trial for ahmad aubry the murder trial
just wanted to ask how you're doing in
this current moment in general with
everything going on well thanks for
asking yeah it is a bit much for all of
us to deal with with covet
with the global pandemic with the racial
reckoning that we're undergoing still
the trial of ahmad arbury and i write
about him
in my
uh book a long time coming reckoning
with race in america so it's a lot for
us as a community but i'm holding up
holding up the bloodstained banner of
truth
and commitment to the faith that my
ancestors have passed on to me
that my role models have given to me so
i'm uh i'm in good shape and uh glad to
be here with you this morning excellent
well i appreciate that and uh just the
importance of the path that's been
blazed before us uh from the ancestors
so i appreciate you mentioning that as
well um the other thing i wanted to ask
you know i heard one of your one of your
recent interviews on the uh the
breakfast club when you were just
talking about you know coming up and not
necessarily thinking about self-care per
se and how you're going about things but
you know just thinking about who you are
as a person all the conversations that
you're continually involved in a lot of
heavy topics how do you manage all of
that in the midst of just trying to
think about your own you know emotional
wellness and care in the midst of that
yes sir well i credit the younger
generation with giving us your
generation and even those younger
uh with uh forcing us to confront this
you know we avoided it uh we were
traumatized re-traumatized and felt that
we had to go on regardless and i think
there's something to be said for that
uh mindset but there's also something to
be said
for reckoning with your own internal
clock
your rhythm your cadence your flow uh
your mental health your stability your
outlook uh your anxiety meter your
depression
measure uh because we're all bombarded
relentlessly and constantly from both
external uh stimuli and forces
and internal uh realities that we
confront perceptions thoughts emotions
uh memories that haunt us
that trigger us so
uh it is extremely necessary to do
uh that kind of inventory you know i
like sports events going out and looking
at basketball and football and watching
movies
so uh those are some of the things that
keep me going uh keep me refreshed
uh and the like and listening to music
and and so on going to a concert and so
on those kinds of things are extremely
important trying to get in an exercise
regimen get in better shape you know
because you got to be here in order to
be here and um
so i think the younger generation has
reminded us of the politics of self-care
and the necessity
of engaging it without the kind of guilt
that older people did without lapsing
into some of the extremes
of uh self-care because if self-care
comes at the expense of other care or
myopic narcissistic self-preoccupation
at the expense
of commitment to the larger society
was it good for martin luther king jr to
do all he did if he was really concerned
about self-care would he have marched on
some days no would he have spoken on
some other days no so you got to balance
out you know a commitment to a higher
purpose and a greater goal
with also
the recognition
that you've got to be here and in good
space and spirits and body and in health
and mind in order to render the best
service possible
yeah that's so good and it sounds like
you have so many of those pieces just
baked in to what you do on a daily basis
but i think it's really you touched on
the generational difference too and i
even see that myself you know even with
younger trainees there coming up it
seems like they're so invested in so
many different things which i felt like
in some ways i kind of waited till i got
to a certain level of stature before i
really jumped into some of those
passions even though those passions were
there how was that process for you in
terms of you know developing your
passions and pursuing them how did that
come about how did you get to this place
in your career being so involved in so
many different spheres of influence
well as they say in basketball i took
what the defense gave me
so it's what opportunities and obstacles
presented themselves some doors opening
other doors closing
and some windows being lifted and some
being nailed shut uh it doesn't mean
that i have a fatalistic outlook and
perspective that suggests that if it's
difficult therefore it's not for me
that's not the case but if you keep
banging your head against the window and
knocking against the door and it ain't
opening then consider opening another
door considering that door ain't for you
considering that god might be looking
out for you what you asking for
ain't what you need to have uh without
being uh paternalistic or uh masking
human authoritarianism with an appeal to
um
you know god's providence but at the end
of the day you gotta have a sense of
connection and spiritual attunement
so that you are constantly praying for
the best path looking for the best
opportunity uh trying to create uh the
next level of investment and the return
on that investment and what your
spiritual growth
and your career growth and your
professional growth and your vocational
growth will be
so for me
it's been a measure of trying to
match my goals and my gifts
what goals are dictated by my gifts now
you might want to be a basketball player
there are some who are my height maybe
five ten
you know babies
thomas
what was that there's some good examples
that you're not some good examples but
the fact that they're relatively few
would suggest
that that ain't you know the likelihood
as opposed to person six five six ten
and so on
so uh so or what are your skills and
what are your intuitions generated uh as
a result of
and so when i look at what my
intuitional base is it's premised on an
intellectual engagement with the world
an analysis of things as they are a kind
of spiritual connection to them as an
ordained minister as an intellectual as
a professor
you know i developed those
talents of thinking and reflecting and
writing and engaging the world and as a
result of that doors open opportunities
presented themselves and i began to
reinforce the value of my
self-perception and
linking my goals and my gifts
and i think if more of us would link our
goals and gifts
we would understand you know how it is
that uh what god has placed in us
can be elicited can be a vote can be
brought out
as a result of whatever circumstances
opportunities or obstacles present
themselves that you know encourage us
coerce us
uh to deal with what's around us so you
know my pastor coming to my church at
when i was 12 years old me in in uh
entering a oratorical contest when i was
11 years old uh being asked to speak
parts in church when i was younger than
that
my fifth grade teacher mrs james
teaching us about black history when it
wasn't popular in 1968
uh in winning a blue ribbon for reciting
the poetry of paul lawrence dunbar and
on and on and on so
my gifts matched uh you know and
dictated to a degree my goals if this is
my skill set if these are my gifts and
talents
what do i use them to
realize and what ambitions uh do i
nurture in my own heart and mind in
order uh to find that re that
relationship between my gifts and my
goals and that allow me to live a
satisfying life so that's how i've tried
to play it so far yeah that's really
powerful and the fact that you remember
your fifth grade teacher's name that's
saying something oh man she was
extremely important uh life-changing you
know my mother told me later that many
of the black parents because i'm in a
segregated school even though i'm living
up north in detroit
uh we had a white principal mrs
christensen i remember but we had black
teachers and black staff and everything
else was black in that school including
the students
and my mother said they went to mrs
christensen and complained to her the
black some of the black parents about
the black
fifth grade teacher mrs james what are
what you know what are they going to do
with this black history stuff this is
not part of the curriculum well i'll
tell you i'm a phd from princeton
university and i've written 25 books and
i write about politics and race and
culture
and religion and all the stuff that she
taught us then so mrs james your efforts
paid off wow yeah such a legacy and such
an impact
i love how you put those two together in
your following you're putting your goals
and your passions together you know i'm
just thinking you know in terms of some
of our listeners and just things i've
heard from people who might say well i
have these goals and these passions but
i don't have any opportunities
to to
to actually carry those things out or
run into obstacles even as you talked
about trying to have that discernment
about knowing when to push through
something if there's resistance but also
knowing when to shift so how have you
done that in your life when those
obstacles have come up and how would you
you know give advice to others who may
be listening who are saying well i have
these passions and goals but i just
can't find a lane or an avenue to really
move that stuff forward
well that's part of the the deal right
that's part of the package if you don't
have a lane if you don't have an
opportunity after so many tries after so
many attempts and there's no measure no
metric that is scientifically uh rooted
you don't know if it's 10 years or 10
days
you know it's depending upon what your
spirit is what your outlook is how much
cash you got what you need to do in the
meantime how many kids you got who you
got to raise what parents you need to
address their situation so all of these
existential measures
uh are
indices our our marks are
metrics uh
that we deploy to
to to determine
how how much stick-to-itiveness we
should display in a particular pursuit
you know some people you know tony
morrison wasn't a professional writer
too but she was what 39 years old
imagine had she given up we would have
missed
arguably the greatest
american writer of her generation the
greatest black writer ever
and uh we would have missed out on sula
or we would have missed out on milkman
dead we would have missed out on
um
you know uh beloved and so on and so
forth and you know we would have missed
out on her genius so thank god she was
persistent but she had a job in the
meantime she was an editor at random
house she was editing angela davis's
work she was working with tony k bombara
so she was nurturing talent as she was
nurturing her own her job was one thing
her vocation another her vision yet
another yeah uh if you can find a space
as i tell my sons and daughter
find something you would do
if nobody paid you a dime and then
figure out a way to make money doing it
so you can support yourself so you can
support your dream so there's no exact
scientific calibration there's no exact
scientific measure or metric or meter or
gold uh
determiner it's what you're made of and
it's what you're looking at and it's how
much you're able to sustain yourself in
the midst of that and how tenacious you
are
willing to be in and persistent in the
face of opposition
in the face of opposition so
you know um and in my case you know i
wanted to write i wanted to think i
thought i was going to be a a
a minister i am a minister who was a
pastor but i went i passed the three
different churches got kicked out of the
third one uh because i was trying to
ordain three women as deacons back in
83.
and uh that door closed on me now i'm
still committed to gender justice in the
church
but maybe the pastorate wasn't the path
for me and so when that door closed
rather precipitously you know i began to
focus
on becoming a scholar and using my gifts
that way and maybe my ministry was in
the classroom and not in the pulpit
alone
or primarily
and so you get signals and hints and
indications again how do you know which
one is for you or not it's a it's an
experimentation yeah it's a trial and
error
uh sometimes trial and terror
uh because the lack of fulfillment can
terrorize you can talk a lot can
tantalize you can traumatize you
so you got to figure it out you know
what are your resources what are your
internal
senses of things what are your
intuitions about what you're doing and
how much more you can take you know we
say god doesn't put anything on you that
you can't take any more on your plate
than you can consume or any more weight
on your shoulders that you can bear
sometimes that's a tough tough way to go
yeah but
having said that in my case
testing as the bible says test the
spirits testing out what my gifts and
goals were as i reshaped my goals
premised upon my gifts or the particular
moment in which i was able to realize
those goals and ambitions because i had
my goals and i had my gifts but i didn't
have as you said the opportunity to
realize them what do i do in the
meantime how do i realize it how do i
recognize there's more than one way to
get to a particular goal if you live in
new york and you're trying to get to
broadway there are many ways to many
more streets and avenues to get there uh
to that street so you gotta look at
alternative routes and and the like
so when you put all that together uh it
gives you a sense of how much you're
willing to invest how long you're
willing to invest it how much you're
capable of sustaining yourself in the
midst of that and everything ain't for
everybody
every route is not for everybody else
your route is unique and different than
my route so but if we have uh the same
goal of realizing our ambitions
and the willingness to stick to it
sometimes that determines
even more than talent just the ability
to sit your butt in the seat and keep
writing keep thinking keep talking keep
doing what you do just outlasting
everybody else until your opportunity
comes yeah so you've got to be moved by
the measure
and the moment
of the spirit within the sense of within
the intuition from within and the
downright dogged determination to do
what you got to do until you can reach
your goals i mean all of that is a
measure
of what to do and there's no scientific
way to tell anybody to do it mm-hmm
and i i definitely appreciate that even
as a scientist because as you said that
that's just not the way it flows and
just that uh
that persistence and the passion
regardless of the doors closing even as
you were sharing aspects of your story
as well
you talk a little bit about the
generational differences some of the
positive generational differences in
terms of really incorporating
that self-care and having a balance in
that way too from your lens and your
perspective have you also seen any
generational differences in terms of
expectations because you touched on that
you know some of these things didn't
happen in a minute they may have taken
10
months 10 years and how do you keep that
passion
while the prize isn't there like you not
to break it down too much generously but
i was curious from your you know yeah
you've seen over the years
yeah no i think there are generational
differences some of us exaggerate them
because
genre may be more important than
generation by which i mean if you were a
hustler a hundred years ago you might be
a hustler today
you were tenacious a hundred years ago
you might be tenacious today a certain
kind of personality that bucked the
system you could have been that turner
then you could be stacey abrams now so
the genre the measure the spirit the
approach the style
of difference
could persist over space and time
[Music]
on the other hand you could be male you
know frederick douglas then you could be
malcolm x now
and so on
um
you could be
um
harriet tubman then
um you can be cheryl and ifill now now
having said that i think there are
differences of generation in terms of
expectation because look at the load the
burden that's put on this generation can
you imagine if we i mean i didn't have
facebook coming up i had to face the
book and read it
it's only facebook face that book boy
and read it you know i didn't have
twitter i was a twitter i was excited
about stuff you know uh swipe left white
white
you know uh
what's that thing they call the when you
did the dating service uh
when you're swiping and stuff tender
yeah we have to be tender in our
emotions toward the people we loved but
we ain't had no tender to figure out top
of this than i am i gotta say yeah
who to date i mean social media is a
game changer and in many ways it's been
extraordinary um
the internet has been extraordinary
stuff it took you look i had to go to
the library
to figure out where the lies were buried
and dig them up goodness and come into
books
you had to go to the library the the
periodical readers catalog all that you
have to go to the you know to find out
what article was published in what year
man that that was shoe leather that was
pavement that was physical
geography
and archaeology of knowledge in books
which i love i still do smelling them
going to bookstores and libraries where
you can just browse i wasn't even
looking for that book and it popped up
professor addy and what is going on and
i didn't even know about that and that's
amazing now you can browse
even more uh rings of gigs of data uh on
the internet stuff that used to take us
you know weeks you can now have at your
fingertips and archives of knowledge and
digitized books and libraries it's
phenomenal
on the other hand
man
there's the expectation is out of order
you know you're going to be immediately
successful if you're not we're going to
note it on twitter you didn't do well
your book didn't sell as much and your
you know
work doesn't pay off as quickly as
others because now you're measuring not
just the person in your own neighborhood
or in your own classroom you're
measuring yourself against all of the
people on twitter all of the people on
facebook all of the people on
instagram and you looking at what
they're doing and you figuring you ain't
got what they got and so on now it's not
that keeping up with the joneses didn't
prevail before but if you didn't have
the instagram to see somebody posting up
archiving their lives in a way
that ain't really the truth got filters
on there they ain't really what they
look like they got cellulite or sell you
heavy whatever they selling you anyway
so the point is all this stuff now
filters and
you know stories and archiving your life
in a way that's not organic necessarily
i'm not crapping on it
it's another outlet but dad gum there
are some lethal deleterious consequences
to that as well and also in terms of
expectation people going to be perfect
and live a certain kind of life you
sitting up on the internet judging
people you sitting up on twitter
administering canceled culture i know it
ain't popular to talk about it people
say all council courses doesn't exist
that's the right wing phenomenon they
don't want to be held accountable that's
true
for many people who are conservative
or or
not the same thing people who are racist
or sexist or transphobic or homophobic
and all that they just don't want to be
called out so i get that
on the other hand
there is something about this
self-righteousness that you judging
other people that you can't make a
mistake or if you make a mistake you
can't overcome it and acknowledge you
did it no you're canceled you're done
that's that's that's ludicrous that's
crazy no room for growth there is no
room for growth because you can't admit
you messed up and now nobody can admit
that they made an error because if you
admit you made an error
then you can't say nothing
and you can't talk about it and you
can't open yourself up to it there's no
continuum there's no spectrum
to be had here there's no difference you
know and and some of these feminists who
were you know talking about certain
things be treating women worse than
anybody else some of these anti-racists
hate black people more than anybody else
so i'm saying like dog slow down with
that kind of judgment because i think
you're from behind the scenes i know the
kind of funky stuff you doing
and okay you can grow you can develop
you can have an organic relationship
with truth and
you know um
evolution of mind and so on and you know
all of us need the space to admit we
messed up and grow but nobody can do it
nobody can say they messed up now nobody
can acknowledge
that they have
made a mistake because to acknowledge
that mistake is to immediately be judged
and to be done away with and to have the
swift you know digital lynch mob descend
upon you know vulnerable people and
we're all vulnerable people so we can
never mess up we can never fess up and
then dress up and move on to the next
situation and i'm i'm you know that that
to me is destructive it's painful
and it's problematic to the ins degree
yeah yeah totally agree with that and
i'm curious what you think on how we
actually cultivate that because that's
such an important piece i mean i'm
saying there's no room for growth we
aren't perfect people we don't have room
to grow we're not going to get through
the challenges and get to a place of
healing and then even as i think about
that and tie that back into mental
health not to say that mental health
challenges are an area where people have
messed up but it's an area of struggle
and so i think that same kind of feeling
comes into the mental health piece too
where people are struggling there's no
room to say i'm struggling because that
looks like imperfection so how do we
actually cultivate that and get to a
healthier place where we can all
actually grow and heal and move forward
and get off of this
facade as it were
yeah no it's a great point i mean stop
lying to yourself
and admit to yourself you messed up but
you can't do it because if i admit to
myself i messed up then i got impostor
syndrome i don't think i belong there
and then mentally look at what you're
doing the mendacity the lies the thick
coat of lies you talk about self-help or
you talking about you know self-care how
are you going to care about yourself if
you can't tell yourself the truth but
you can't you can't tell yourself the
truth because if you tell yourself the
truth when you acknowledge some of the
stuff that's going on then you'd have to
tell others that same truth and you'd
have to admit that you ain't as perfect
as it appears that you are
and i and again
the the social structure then prevents
individual consciousness the
individuation that is a measure of
psychological health the ability to
individuate to establish a basis of
individual ego driven in the best sense
of that word
recognition and self-identification with
those goals and aspirations nurtured in
you that produce a healthy outcome
a healthy ego a healthy sense of self
whether you're dealing with analytical
psychology of carl gustav young or you
know the psychoanalytic framework of
freud or the indirect approach of rogers
or you know the best of black
psychological uh therapy that joins a
consciousness of anti-blackness to the
the kind of self-hatred that might be
uncritically or unconsciously
internalized whatever
at the end of the day if you can't
acknowledge that if you can't fess up
and say dad gum it i messed up or i'm
not perfect and i need help it's it's a
contradictory message on the one hand
self-care is about i'm not well enough
today i'm naomi osaka i can't follow
through i'm simone biles i can't follow
through and so on
and then if you admit that
and then if you say but then you know
part of the blame could be that i'm not
ready i didn't prepare i'm
psychologically not ready for the world
that is hurting me oh what what's wrong
so you know it's it's tough out here to
be able to do that so you've got to have
a world create scenes
cosmoses uh you know world views uh
intimate connections uh communities
uh gatherings um organizations
where you're able to share that
knowledge be safe a safe place where you
can tell the truth
and not be immediately judged and one
person's safe space is another person's
vulnerability and even if if people
insist on they're having safe spaces
they're developing those uh at the
expense of forcing others uh to bow down
before their narrow conception of what
is appropriate and good and healthy and
uplifting so we got to be honest about
this stuff and stop holding each other
to un reasonable standards and and uh
unrighteous attempts
uh to assault people out of
self-righteousness righteousness now yes
there's a way in which you can hold each
other accountable even as we recognize
our faults and flaws it doesn't mean
that therefore anything goes and as long
as i say i messed up i don't have to be
accountable yes we all have to be held
accountable there are things that i've
done that of which i am enormously
ashamed and i can say that openly but
man man i can't really get too specific
about it because if i get too specific
then others you know begin to chime in
and yep and and hate on you while
they're not admitting the stuff that
they did
you know some sins are more visible than
others some flaws are more evident than
others others are emotional sins or
internal psychological sins that we
commit against self or others uh bad
words bad thoughts uh accompanying bad
deeds so you know we got to be extremely
careful and cautious about the
judgmentalism and the harshness that
goes in the name of politically correct
or even woke ideology about holding
people to account if martin luther king
jr could forgive white supremacists and
racists and people who were killing
black
some more love to people other
and we showed to the white people who
are trying to murder us back in the day
and so we're doing it today yeah
wow there's a lot there so it's almost
just important um and things i think we
can really pull pull apart one one piece
i want to ask a little bit more and kind
of dig deep in is this idea of
individual versus community because you
talked about you know how we haven't
paid attention to that in terms in terms
of our self-care but i'm curious just
even in terms of the historical context
of that
in this country and what the you know
such the the emphasis on
the community suffering that was
happening and kind of the importance of
resilience is a word that gets thrown
around for good or for bad i mean we
could dig into that as well but how how
do we balance those twos because in one
sense it seems that the individual's
individualism was squelched in order so
that we could thrive as a community at
the same time that could happen at the
expense of the individual so how do we
how do we balance that in our current
moment because there are even ways that
that happens today even again thinking
about the mental health aspect thinking
about some of the work that david
williams has done at harvard just
showing the negative mental health
impacts
in black and brown communities in states
where individuals have been killed at
the hands of police unarmed individuals
and right effect that has on the
community and on the individual so i
guess i'm trying you know how do we
tease those pieces apart because they're
both important but there's consequences
of leaning too heavily on one side
or the other
yeah no doubt i mean david williams joy
degree you know when you think about the
uh post-slave syndrome
uh
post-slave trauma traumatic syndrome
uh where she speaks about the trauma we
endure collectively
as an enslaved people
um
so
and brother williams so yeah the the
psychological consequence
but they've also done psychological
studies of hope that people who hope
unrealistically suffered just as much
like woo so it's deep now
you got too much unrealistic hope you
jacked up uh you're too pessimistic
you're jacked up you're too nihilistic
you're jacked up damn gum what's what's
a what's the brother to do what's the
system to do
uh so the thing is is that yeah there
are community trauma communities that
are traumatized when we see black people
who are subject to the vicious um
you know assault of a dominant white
supremacist society
that traumatizes all of us
and our individuality is wiped away the
the irony is the struggle of the
collective is for the individual to be
acknowledged don't treat us like dad gum
parts of the same community only in
terms of your stereotype
all black people are lazy all black
people uh you know are unfaithful to the
task at hand right all black people are
and fill in the blanks everything you
say about black people is true about
everybody every group
but you begin to stereotype and
rigorously or you know don't apply rigor
to your deconstruction of those
practices uh dispositions habits and
inclinations
of
of black people to behave in a certain
way
and that they're not just black
everybody does that right every
community that is poor will engage in
criminal activity every community whose
back is against the wall right poles
jews italians you know in this country
who were in the shadow in the ghetto
before african people in america
um
at the same time the unique condition of
being enslaved
in this country uh and then being you
know
then having the force and power of the
state turned against us
and denying our humanity that has to be
acknowledged too and the psychological
consequences of that so yes there's a
psychological consequence to being
treated as a group all black people and
fill in the blanks all black people fill
in the blanks all black people fill in
the blanks the stereotypes
the narrow conceptions and the
stereotype is a lazy person's way of
dealing with the other some of it some
small part of it could be true but the
vast majority of the data rests upon a
refusal to acknowledge the person before
me and to put the group before all jews
all polls all italians all lithuanians
um
and and all polish and blah blah blah
you know do x y and z as opposed to
dealing with the individual person
jewish italian polish
um you know korean uh before me
uh while at the same time acknowledging
that there are group traits that are
developed as a result
of having imposed upon those groups
certain restrictions
so that a group consciousness has
developed but you mad at us
wow you black people got to come
together as a group why can't you be
treated as an individual that's when
they want they don't want to deal with
the racism question the structural
characteristics of racism well be
treated as an individual but you don't
treat us as individuals you continually
treat us as members of a particular
group that you stereotype or you're
prejudiced against so you go up to a
black person you don't even know and
hate them because they're black that
ain't got nothing to do with the
individual data experience uh engagement
with that person you're treating us as a
collective
so it's collective when it's convenient
it's
individual uh when it's to the
to the delight or benefit
of of that particular person or
community assessing us
so yeah you got the individual stuff on
the one hand
where if we're treated as individuals
exceptions from the group that's
problematic you're better than dr addy
you're better than
most of the other people that i've met
of your color and you're got a better
character and you're more you're
hard-working and going go praise you at
the expense of your group through the
means of a stereotype that dishonors the
group
and therefore exaggerates or distorts
the individual
so yeah that stuff is tough
uh no doubt and there are you know
issues on both sides as a collective as
an individual
and we've got to confront those we got
to acknowledge our group solidarity and
we've got to acknowledge our quest for
individual expression so that we don't
impose those restraints on each other
you know you ain't really black cause
you scuba dive you know you ain't really
black cause you're trans no you ain't
really black because you queer no you
ain't really black cause you
afrofuturist you ain't really black
because you like country music you ain't
really black because you only listen to
beethoven and not bust the rhymes and on
and on and on so we impose these
constraints impose these narrow limits
on ourselves as well now that's not to
say
that those who operate within our
communities who are hurting and harming
black people who self-hate and as a
result of that other hate
uh that's real too
but everybody who's not part of the
group and the maine is not a self-hater
and doesn't want to undermine
the capacity of black people to move
forward as a community they want to
argue for some oxygen to breathe the air
that they feel most comfortable inhaling
so it's a constant battle it's a
constant pivoting between toggling
between the collective and the
individual but the the the corrosive
consequences
of both of seeing our black people
traumatizing regardless of our you know
our economic status or our racial you
know beliefs or our religious
orientation or our sexual orientation on
the one hand and there's the stuff we do
to each other to impose narrow
constraints and judgments on each other
and it's what we have to put up with in
a society that wants to touch our hair
that wants to believe
that microaggressions are
harmless of the carings of the world to
dictate where we can eat and not eat
sell
water and not sell water lemonade not
lemonade barbecue not barbecue
go into
um
you know a coffee shop and be treated as
a thug and the like or at a university
and be seen as out of place so all of
that stuff we're constantly trying to
negotiate between
and it's even more havoc wreaked
when we impose those narrow
vicious beliefs on each other as well
yeah yeah and so what's up because all
the tensions between the two as you
mentioned um you know i'm curious from
your your perspective as a sociologist
and this i know all the other hats that
you wear too you talked you talked about
you know all the things all the risks of
being a black person in this country as
you've just gone through i know you
mentioned that in your convocation
address at meharry medical college as
well
how does that how do you see that
impacting
our mental health in general and just
our outlook in the world and how do we
actually try and move through that you
know not necessarily maybe from a mental
health lens or right psychiatric or
psychological lens but from your
perspective as a sociologist like what
are healthy ways that we can actually
how one how does it impact us the more
healthy ways we can move through that to
still thrive and not have this false
sense of hope that you talked about
yeah well you know
you want to have as clear
a concept of your capacities as possible
so that you can have a realistic
assessment of your likely trajectory of
success and achievement in the world you
got to figure out ways to have a
realistic assessment of self in regard
to obstacles that might prevent the
flourishing of that self
and therefore negotiate a world that is
constantly throwing up obstacles and
you're constantly
through resilience trying to overcome
them trying to engage them but also use
them as grist for your meal
as a story in your larger narrative of
success or overcoming
so
you got to be as cunning and as clever
and as crafty as our ancestors you know
uh faking like they liked stuff when
they didn't like it uh you know yes so
massa when they were like
giving them the bird behind the scene or
putting um shall we say urination into
their water to make it taste better
finding everyday forms of resistance
aborting babies sometimes from
enslavement breaking tools and
implements hey it don't work what you
want me to do breaking the legs of
animals so that they couldn't
you know be used and deployed and
enslaved to work so they were all kind
of crafty cunning creative
clever ways we found to negotiate
now i don't want any animals to be hurt
and i don't want any tools to be broken
unnecessarily uh but i'm talking about
an approach a mindset a mental health
strategy that says that at all costs i
must maintain my belief that god has
blessed me the universe has blessed me
if you don't believe in god that i am
who i am as a result of the talent i
have i should be able to recognize that
talent in a in a goal-oriented society
that throws up impediments and
you know um things that prevent my
flourishing
i've got to constantly fight against
that i got to fight against the
self-doubt that has been implanted not
because of an inherent sense of
inferiority but by an imposed one
that has been inherited from a dominant
white supremacist logic that continues
to constrain
who i am or a sense of self in the midst
of that
so mental health you gotta you know
maintain
you know like look i'm worthy i'm good
it's all right to acknowledge my
vulnerabilities and my faults and my
flaws but also to stand up and to
celebrate my achievements the vast
region of possibility that i have barely
begun to tap
that is open to me and i must insist on
realizing that ambition
uh that's a mentally healthy thing to do
you know the new movie king richard is
coming out where richard williams the
father of venus and serena had to fight
a bunch of stereotypes he's crazy he's
got two daughters what does he know he
has no experience with tennis and he's
in compton in the concrete jungle what
the hell does he know well enough to
produce two of the greatest tennis
players ever one arguably the greatest
tennis player ever bargender
another one one of the greatest of all
time in venus
so
yeah he was crazy like a fox
mentally spiritually emotionally uh
against the grain looking unorthodox
sometimes we have to be unorthodox
sometimes we have to be on the margins
we can't be in the main
uh
the mainstream uh you have to flow in
the way in the cadence uh
that has been given to you the moral
ambitions that have been nurtured in you
the styles the
the measures and means that are
most akin to your flourishing that don't
hurt or harm others so in terms of
mental health yeah you know you got to
figure out ways to affirm self to love
self to embrace self as other selves
creatively engage in the same process
fighting for opportunities opening doors
not feeling that your success
um is harmed if another person's success
uh is present
a lot of things we can do
to reinforce our sense of self go to
church go to temple go to synagogue read
a religious book a half set of
affirmations have goals that are
articulated on refrigerator doors
and on and on and on read the you know
the bhagavad-gita the holy quran the
taliching whatever it is that floats
your boat superman batman
comic books you know rap lyrics little
wayne
dr dre
jay-z uh lauren hill you know whatever
it takes to sustain you listen to anita
baker or luther vandross or whatever it
is that uplifts you that gives you the
confidence and courage and conviction uh
to move forward and have a strong
uh self-concept a mentally healthy
outlook that keeps at bay the demons of
depression and distress and anxiety
that eat away at the fabric of your
self-confidence
uh in this world
so well said and i love all the pieces
that you pulled in because there's so
much of that that ties into the the
brain science and neuroscience of what
we need moving forward to even as you
talked about the expectation that we
have for ourselves or the importance of
community or the importance of music and
how that really engages you know reward
pathways in our brain they're important
for helping us kind of move through
things on a day-to-day basis so
it's great hearing that you know that
perspective from you as a minister
sociologist and professor and how that
ties in so strongly to neuroscience
about what it really means for our
brains and helps us to move through some
of these challenges in a lot of ways um
as well again loose back to what you
mentioned earlier on i think too about
that that balance between
uh the self-care and then also kind of
moving through things but not trying to
sway one way or the other but i mean the
way that you kind of painted that
picture for really having a holistic
balance and
really having those pieces baked in as
you mentioned i think is is so powerful
and i imagine that you know even if it
hasn't been something that you've stated
throughout your you know your long
career it seems like you have those
pieces in place to really kind of
keep those pieces in check in a sense
yes certainly no no well stated eloquent
more eloquently than i did but yes sir
and those neural pathways that develop
those endorphins that are released those
the psycho-chemical psychoneurochemical
you know possibilities that are
unleashed if it's good for your soul is
good for your your endorphins it's good
for the biology it's good for the
neurotransmitters that carry messages of
hope and aspiration and possibility
without being you know narrowly uh
retrofitted as positive as opposed to
deeply rooted in hope because so hope
confronts the negative confronts the
horrible confronts the terrorizing the
traumatizing and then gives answer uh to
those
pathways that that portend nuclear
explosion in your brain
and redirect them towards something more
powerful and uplifting and beautiful and
edifying
at the same time
totally agreed full circle a lot of ways
i know we're running short on time but
they want you to give you a chance to
talk about your upcoming book um as well
because i know that's going to be
released very soon and yes sir what
should readers expect from this latest
uh this latest gifting well thank you
sir uh entertaining race performing
blackness in america is the kind of
collection of stuff i've been doing for
nearly the last 30 years
sermons essays
uh reviews
film
um
you know interviews with me and others
um commencement speeches or protest
speeches
uh op-eds every genre i've got a
restless fascination with literacy
and expression and how to articulate
ideas and
aspirations that are not limited to one
genre
um
and so people will get a chance to peek
into my own spirit my mind my soul
my desires my ambitions
my thoughts
and uh see me reckoning and wrestling uh
with them out loud in public spaces that
allow others to be challenged to be
championed
uh
and hopefully to be uplifted
uh
at the same time uh to do their own
thing to express themselves in ways that
are appropriate and uplifting not only
to themselves but to to the communities
around them
well i look forward to reading i mean
even the way you just characterize that
i love the fact that it has that
wrestling the wrestling and the hope
together because as we were talking that
seems i mean that's the key piece so
that we don't get in this facade of not
having to work through things to get to
a place of hope and healing so yes sir
thank you my brother well i appreciate
you taking the time again to be on the
addie hour this is a conversation i
think a lot of people are going to go
back to and probably listen to a few
times to catch all the nuances and
nuggets that you uh you dropped
throughout so really appreciate your
your time with us and just for joining
this conversation
thanks for having me keep up that
extremely important work of keeping us
on the right path of mental health
mental well-being
emotional security in the midst of
vulnerability thank you so much for the
work you do my friend of course so my
pleasure glad to contribute in a
meaningful way
thank you sir
[Music]